[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
happy sunday it's a great day for
football
we are officially in the second half of
the season and unlike the jets we are
not
tanking for trevor lawrence welcome to
the uh welcome to the squad ride
presented by draftkings live in the
bluetooth report app my name is cabbie
richards
in the middle is our betting expert and
big bankroll that is kelly stewart
and on the end it's the wizard of
winners only wednesdays
good morning to you both listen uh this
is the show where we bet anytime
touchdowns and as the poet marshawn
lynch once said
we bout that action boss we are six and
three on the squad ride so far this year
and a few days ago we asked you on
social to make a creative video
with your favorite touchdown score this
week so we got a fresh new field with
some familiar names and these are the
most
popular picks by you the audience
suggested to score anytime touchdowns i
like that
josh jacobs has made the list we got a
nick chubb sighting mike evans is in the
mix
this is a great field in week 10.
okay so we have five legendary videos
which we're going to show you to decide
our week 10 squad ride
as for action here are some wild moments
from the last week
[Music]
russ what else can you say mvp
christian the catholic
oh my god
omg indeed jimmy generous uh greg ivory
even though your squad
is facing new orleans today and the uh
the audience appreciates
your generosity before kickoff
and before the annihilation so how do
you feel about giving away hoodies right
now
cabbie relax relax brother but is it
time
is it time are you telling me it's time
it's game time it's game time it's
hoodie time baby let's get it
i'm on my handy dandy ipad i'm in the
comments shimmy burger yo greg
we cold out here come on let me see some
hoodies from the goat
brother you're walking away with a
hoodie i'm back into the comments
uh christmas must have come early this
year's because grega claus is already
handing out presents
the 26 ui you're walking away with
hoodie now cabbie let me give you some
takes here
jay will 2886 says devonta
adams will score twice today he's boring
i like it
so for being bold i'm giving him a
hoodie cabbie well thank you
i'm just i'm just gonna give him a
hoodie and and uh
you guys give me more takes in the
comments i'm gonna give away more
hoodies
okay well let's get the competition
started this is a last person tournament
let the battles begin in round one our
first pitch comes from carter mack
uh 34. who's scoring a touchdown today
carter
i need your help this weekend i got five
players here i need you to tell me which
one's a lot to score a touchdown this
sunday
i got miles sanders mike davis nick
chubb
mike evans and will fuller who's your
law
miles sanders is a lock there you go
thank you very much
yes dana okay so guys or audience get
ready for your first tough decision
today because his opponent
is naughty little boy what do you got
homie
all right you juggle these three balls
and you pick one after i'm done all
right
all right which one
this
[Applause]
lock it in baby
walking in nick chubbs shout out to the
virginia tech hockey sweater i don't
think i've ever
seen any normally played hockey in
virginia tech but either way dope jersey
okay you've heard him you've heard the
first two pitches miles sanders with
philadelphia
versus nick chubb with cleveland tell us
in the comments who should move on
g money what do you think of our pitches
from nana legend
and the circus legend cavi
nana legend is a legend she she needs to
be
goated right now i'm just loving the way
i'm just
loving the way she pondered she thought
about it
and she was very confident in the mile
sanders pick
i mean mouse sanders coming off of
injury sitting at 121
i don't dislike that pick from nana i
actually kind of love it
now let's talk about the circus legend
and the nick chubbs pick
my guy he got a little creative i'll
give him an a for effort with a juggling
i know i can't juggle
but i mean he he juggled it but
he asked his mom who like did not know
what was going on with the video she had
no no awareness of what was going on
about what was happening like there was
a lot of girls
in was it his mama
i thought that was mom's i thought that
whoever it was you had to key somebody
in
they got to be a part of it but anyway
let's talk about the picks we got
uh miles sanders coming off of an injury
we got nick chubb coming off of an
injury kelly
talk to me what are you leaning who are
you riding with
i honestly hate both these pics but if
you're gonna make me
choose i'm mad at the dude for wearing
the hokies
hockey jersey why man that was brutal
yesterday that was my best bet
up 24-13 and what happened
quarterback throws a pig defense can't
play lockdown
that was just absolutely an abomination
i should have won that game no sweat
and to be honest i got kareem khan on my
fantasy team
why would i want nick chubb to score a
touchdown today and as greg alluded to
both these guys coming off injury
why are we doing these videos here i
like the giants
catching points divisional home dogs
we've been over this i like the browns
there are too many points to lay now i
laid three it's now four four and a half
look i this is tough i'll let the
audience decide because
i want no part of this
perfect you're gonna get you're gonna
get it a
thousand percent from kelly stewart on
every single show
uh regardless of who you pitch uh g
money speaking of the audience
how are they reacting to the the nano
legend and then the juggle circle legend
cabbie i'm back on the handy dandy ipad
get it baby
sasquatch says nick chubb coming back
to take his spot back running hard and
he's running downhill
you're walking away with a hoodie um i
got
wheaton boys saying this man miles is
gonna run
on the giants uh oh he said this man
miles is gonna run for miles
against the giants you're also walking
away with a hoodie
uh kp giant says chubb is still hurt
he's saying that he's gonna play but
he's still hurt sanders is bouncing back
so it's a back and forth in the in the
comments cabbie but i'm going to make a
decision next one i see
yup brooks mcfadden you're walking away
with a hoodie he's walking away with
nick chubb cabbie so therefore
we're moving on with nick chubb in the
circus left okay
first first quarter belongs to natty
natty little boy
for winning round one but as you know
how the game goes you gotta win
three more times to become the squad
ride leader
so round two let's get it our next pitch
comes from jaden ricci
who has a pitch that you may not be able
to refuse
brown was 150 who
antonio brown was one favorite
yes you've heard from nana you've heard
from papa
actually we're gonna call him the
godfather you heard from the godfather
himself tell us in the comments who
should move on to round three
greg jayden ricci went with an iconic
film character
uh in his video what'd you think of his
pitch and salute to the godfather
cabbie i just got a question who antonio
brown
150 who antonio brown
plus 150. it kind of reminded me of the
mike jones back in the day who mike
johnson
you know you know what i'm talking about
kevin yeah but
the godfather legend i mean we should
make this something we should always get
picks from our grandparents
i mean they have the wisdom they have
the knowledge they have the experience
gramps just laid a gym with antonio
crown
plus 150 in a second game coming back uh
kelly talk to me gramps is talk he's
speaking that wisdom with
antonio brown plus 150. how do you see
that matching up against nick chubb
greg you brought up mike jones and
that's a great antonio brown
reference back then they didn't want me
now i'm hot hoes all on me this dude
moves in with tom brady and you guys
want to give him the
touchdown today i don't think so pump
the brakes he is plus 150 for a reason
everybody back up there is still
three other great receivers and oh by
the way
a nice tight end by the name of grunk
that is going to get the ball before
antonio brown does
they are baiting you with this line as
far as the game goes
i leaned the panthers here plus six but
man does tampa bay look great in a
teaser
6.2 team teaser tees them down to just
to pick them
just to win the game i do think tampa
bay bounces back
but we got to leave our grandparents
alone can you let this man live
kelly he has wisdom right yes g-money
i don't think the audience expected
keller to be spitting bars on a sunday
morning this is amazing
is the audience also spitting hot fire
in the comments
cabbie the audience they want to call
their grandparents
my guy d keats deepgeek says i'm gonna
call my grandfather
right after the show make sure you call
them send in the video we want to get
them on
yes uh k coupe 4 says ab scoring two
times today
ooh you're bold right there you're
walking away with a hoodie uh sloan 58
says
still with nick chubb i think he's it's
proven
uh and it's time again he's a semi truck
on the field tampa has to find that
chemistry again
so it's back and forth gabby the next
one i read we're rocking with
how about that okay here we go uh
i got my guy theo 26 ui never a doubt
the grandfather
a b finna go crazy today give me two
touchdowns
kelly making a big mistake
we're walking away with a hoodie brother
but uh i don't know if kelly's making a
mistake
but cabbie with that being said we're
rocking with the grandfather
we're walking with we're walking with
the grandfather and antonio brown moving
on to the next round
okay wonderful round two we are rolling
with the godfather legend
who's relying on the goat tom brady to
get antonio brown
at least one touchdown that's how we're
doing it in round two two rounds down
two more to go
let's start round three next up is jake
winchester with some
like dustin johnson vibes who do you
have just who do you have is a lot to
score touchdown in week 10.
all these balls have an anytime
touchdown score locked this sunday
whatever one hits we're riding
[Music]
looks like we got two
and they're both will fuller
because that man's cash
wait a second it was that i feel like
there was there's something there
g-money wait is his uh is this short
game better than you at the driving
range
i have no idea and i all i know is that
you saw something and i saw it too that
was a bunch of cap in this video
that's what it was a bunch of cap i mean
the guys they they had it planted it was
will fuller the whole time it was a
bunch of cap
but i mean i i mean i got better at golf
cabbie i got better at golf so my
my my driving game is back it's better
my
driving game is better but let's talk
about the pick
my guy will fuller uh
sitting at plus 150 kelly talk to me
will fuller
antonio brown it's a they're both
valued the same i mean what are you
thinking
uh we already talked about this browns
game a little bit and i think that
the thing that scares me about chubb
versus kareem hunt is hey
chubs hurt b i need kareem hunt on my
fantasy team and c
i think the browns have to focus on the
running game why
the weather is crappy which if the
browns are focusing on the running game
so are the houston texans they got to
keep the ball on the ground nobody wants
to turn it over you don't want to be
throwing bombs
thus will fuller is not going to see
much action today he's plus 150 here for
a reason
look maybe he can slide in the end zone
i like him a little bit better than
antonio brown
i really don't want to choose here this
is what who's in
these videos i mean the videos are
creative but like really
give me give me somebody that's like big
juice that we can odds boost from draft
kings
okay all right we're gonna we're gonna
get to that kels
uh so g money are they you know as as
jake said in the video wolf fuller
scored a touchdown in six straight games
that's a lot of heat
is the audience riding with with jake
winchester are they still riding with
the grandfather legend
the godfather legend cabbie cabbie i'm
in the comments and it's back and forth
uh iron s t dizer says will fuller is
looking to get a td
seven weeks in a row he is cash
uh we have to fact check that one i
don't know if that one's a
accurate but it might be uh john johnny
monopoly says
i'll go with fuller too it seems like
will fuller is in the comments but hold
on hold on i'm seeing a lot of no cap kp
johnson you're walking away with hoodie
that is winners only wednesday
lingo no cap is in the comments a b
is a lock for them bucks g money nico
madrid you're walking away
cabbie okay i i just refreshed it and
i'm seeing a lot of a b
and the godfather they're moving on i
made the decision
okay all right three quarters don't be
in the godfather the guy okay it's
almost yes
to declare the squad ride but the
godfather legend is moving on
taking antonio brown with them the squad
ride voted by you our audience
this is the final round the winner of
this round will be
our squad ride so let's get it our final
pitch comes from riley sorbo
you know his chickens uh pitched us last
week let's see what he's got in store
for week 10.
[Music]
squad ride pick em week 10. let's get
this money
say buddy
oh man it's looking like a runaway
oh my god devonte adams it is lock it in
this is the week with the most adorable
videos we've ever had on squad we got
nana
we got the godfather and now we have a
chameleon this is
incredible this is very this is very
very tough so tell us in the comments
audience
whether we're riding with the godfather
and antonio brown or the chameleon
and devonta adams with the packers uh
greg what'd you think of our final pitch
cabbie i just wish betting was as easy
as picking this pick
uh like i just like like a geico can
pick the pick i mean
man uh also this guy this guy this guy
last week
he was feeding his chickens the same
thing uh
he was feeding his chickens the same and
it looks like cheese i don't know if you
can like
if you see the video it looks like
cheese does geico's eat cheese i mean
is that that's what you feed geico
geckos geico
sorry but anyway anyway you can save up
to 15
on car insurance if you tap in with my
guys but um
let's talk about the pick let's talk
about the pick devonta
adams uh i think he's gonna ball he's
been balling
all year he's sitting at -200 here
uh the gecko i mean he knew what he he
knows football he knows
who who's one of the best wide receivers
is and he took devonta adam so i'm
loving the pick kelly talk to me
we have antonio brown and we have
devante adams what do you think
as the great marshawn lynch once said
protect your chickens and your
chameleons
uh look i think this is a really easy
pick here now i'm not laying the 13 and
a half with the packers but by all means
the packers should beat up on the
jaguars here at home
and by all means davonte adams at 3-1
with our draftkings odds boost is going
to score a touchdown
this is a no-brainer here he picked the
two big favorites on the board dalvin
cook
and devonte adams look bet either one of
those but at three to one devonta
adams is going to score a touchdown
today and
i have a softball in my heart for the
little guy
well done and again just yo kelly
stewart is spitting bars today this is
amazing
so get in the comments vote for your
vote for our winner
while you do that previewing the marquee
matchup of the week
which happens to be in the nfc west the
best division in football kelly stewart
who are you locking in as your best bet
in week 10.
oh cabbie you know what two weeks in a
row
the numbers went against me i told you
guys last week as we were sitting here
doing the show live i was like i hate it
i hate the tampa bay buccaneers why
because the line went from four and a
half all the way down to three
and we're now seeing the opposite with
the seattle seahawks this one was one
and a half now it's two and a half it's
not looking good for my best bet but
the bad news for me is i'm already
locked and loaded and i'm not gonna buy
off of it
uh but i will say this i do think
seattle being a divisional road dog here
is a little interesting i i expect this
team to play
the rams tough and i'm gonna i'm gonna
still rock with it but
head over to our instagram channel i
already gave out the chargers i gave out
the broncos today uh on our twitter page
and don't forget to bet the bears
tomorrow night against the vikings on
monday night football
hopefully we can get there with seattle
but i'm gonna be honest with you guys
i'm feeling a little defeated the last
two weeks
listen it's it's it's time for a bounce
back i love that you're giving the
audience like so many touchdowns so get
on draftkings
lock it in seattle's trying to stay on
top of the division with a road win in
in los angeles it should be an exciting
game thank you to our mvp kelly stewart
all those nuggets right there
let's get rich all right we're right
we're rocking with seattle
greg ivory it's that time in the show
where the uh the decision has been made
by the audience
and we need to know who we're locking in
for our squad ride
because football starts soon and we need
that action boss
cabbie you know where i'm looking at my
handy-dandy ipad there you go
and um i think it's i think it's as
clear as day
i think it's as clear as day donk 25
give adams that 99 overall rating in
madden
yes i do think he's gonna get that real
soon that was a great take dog 25 you're
walking away with a hoodie
um here we go adam's up we're they're
talking about madden again
jacob jacob uh mbnt says adam's chasing
that 99
madden overall rating he's for sure
getting that td
uh cabbie i see adams t gibson this is
the last one adam's
190 yards two tds easily
seattle taking the game by 10 as well
cabbie the people have spoken in the
comments
we are rocking with devonta
adams to score a touchdown today
you see this graphic you see this
graphic it says minus 200 right now
please change the graphic the graphic
needs to be changed right now and there
it is it just changed plus 300
on draftkings you guys can go get that
right now
make sure you guys tune in to the br
betting
instagram story where we will be riding
all day um tap in send me your videos
but remember winners only
please speaking of social
media make sure you click on br betting
on instagram or or twitter to get the
link
for the odds boost that's very important
send us screenshots of your bets
also very important keep sending videos
of your celebrations the most important
because we want to celebrate with you
that's all we do here
we are a family of squad uh this is our
squad and we are riding with devonta
adams of the people gabby cabbie cabbie
cabbie hold on
i want you good luck with your wages and
don't don't chase too much in the 4pm
games cause there's six of them
i'm back into the comments brother i'm
back it's time to give away some more
hoodie
this is what the people want they do do
do do more dj says greg needs to give me
a hoodie
right now wait it's a little grab some
brother please
guess what if there's no please there's
no please but i'm gonna be generous
you're gonna walk away with a hoodie
dj uh the tick man the tick man says
check out my video i sent you all had
the same pick brother since you had the
same picture man
you're also walking away woody cabbie i
got one more in me
i got one more enemy the shimmy burger
says the handy dandy ipod
ipad let's go greg stop flexing that
though stop it brother
stop it but cabbie i'm showing love to
add
adversity in the comments but i'm
showing love you're still walking away
with a hoodie and i'm still going to be
flashing this ipad
greg yes sir you are too generous bro if
the uh if these guys aren't
saying please or thank you if there's no
etiquette you shouldn't be rewarding
them with hoodies
your heart is too big my dude we gotta
we gotta talk about it offline after the
show
uh but listen if you want entertainment
make sure to follow the br betting
instagram
story with jimmy generous greg ivory
because
it's a it's the most fun place to watch
football alongside
uh g-money um congrats to all our hoodie
winners
congrats thank you to all our commenters
thank you to the legends
we got carter mac 34 we have naughty
little boy
jayden richie jake winchester and riley
sorbo also thank you to
nana papa and uh and the gecko um
keeps the videos keep getting better so
we we really appreciate that
keep sending them and next week you'll
have a chance to be a lock legend like
those five
cats alongside kelly stewart greg aubry
my name is cabbie richards
we'll see you guys next week peace
[Music]
you